Sean you put a very eclectic interesting
background in films all very different
what was it that made you want to make
metro manila I wanted to make a foreign
film actually I was very excited about
making a film in a language I didn't
speak and I went to the Philippines on
holiday and witnessed an incident
between two armored truck guys that
ended with one of them kick in the truck
and it just stayed with me and I just
kept thinking what what they arguing
about and so I wrote a story that sort
of had a beginning that middle and and
then how it was going to resolve so that
was basically how it came about how did
you find it interacting in a language
that you don't speak it's interesting um
you concentrate less on like line
delivery and more on sort of body
language and so I started to get the
rhythm of what they were saying rather
than what they were saying and that was
it was actually quite a big relief for
me because you actually realized that a
lot of language is nonverbal and so
therefore watching the actors and just
seeing how they were acting was more
important for me than than what they
were saying I kind of knew what they
were saying because we had the English
version of the script but you know just
stuff like what they were doing with
their eyes what they were doing with the
body the hands that sort of stuff it's
really interesting to tell me about the
locations or did you say you went on
holiday and that's kind of what inspired
this I mean what was it like shooting
there obviously a very different
experience of big on holiday yeah but I
have to say the Filipino people were
just incredible and really supportive of
film and were you know went out their
way to help us and and it couldn't be
made without that help and because we
have very little on it's a very small
independent film and and everyone just
you know gave us so much you know and
it's a it's a lovely change actually
because I think in the UK our favorite
word is no so to actually go to a place
where they actually say yes you can film
there it's actually I was I couldn't
believe my luck finally what's next for
you if we look forward to more films
abroad then I'd like to make more films
in different languages yeah maybe I'll
maybe I'll make up a go do a a world
tour yeah yeah is actually nice we look
forward to that lots of it with metrum
that it's fantastic film livid
tisha
you